why do you think life needs to be
meaningful it does it right so if you
get some days that mean more awesome if
you dab days that don't awesome my
favorite analogy is the sunshine and
Rain which is like we say Sunshine days
or good days rainy days or bad days but
it's just weather yeah and if you're a
fish maybe rainy days are good and
sunshine days are bad yeah so it's just
what you make it mean if you make it
mean different things and it means you
can make anything mean anything which
then means you're in control which is
what I ultimately wanted was like I see
Freedom as being able to just choose how
you want to experience life